>>Mamie Rheingold: You may know Howard Rheingold
as a colorful and prescient anthropologist
who defined concepts like virtual communities
and smart mobs before we were all participating
in them.
You may know him as the former editor of the
'Whole Earth Review' and the founding editor
of 'Hotwired'.
Or perhaps you are a student of Howard's either
at Berkeley or Stanford or his social media
classroom and online learning community Rheingold's
U.
Or maybe you know him for his painted shoes,
paisley blazer, Panama hat and psychedelic
art.
In fact we were in SXSW last month, a street
person came up to him and thank him for keeping
Austin weird.
But I know him as Dad.
So 10 years ago, my dad wrote 'Smart Mobs:
the Next Social Revolution'.
This was years before twitter and 4square,
before NFC and Google wallet.
My dad wrote about a future in which people
will leave messages and places and mobile
phones will become remote controls for the
physical world.
A decade before the Arab Spring and the Occupy
Movement, he predicted that the merger of
mobile phones, personal computers and the
Internet were lowering barriers to collective
action and were going to enable economic,
social and political revolutions.
Sound familiar?
In 1985, he wrote 'Tools for Thought: The
History and Future of Mind Expanding Technology',
in which he envisioned the future of personal
computing when hundreds of millions of people
around the world would be a part of a network
community.
And how this would change the way people think,
learn and communicate.
He warned that nobody knows whether this will
turn out to be the best or the worst thing
that the human race has done for itself because
the outcome of this empowerment will depend
in a large part on how we react to it and
what we choose to do with it.
And in his new book 'Net Smart: How to Thrive
Online', Howard warns that the future of digital
culture depends on how well we learn to use
the media that have infiltrated, amplified,
distracted, enriched and complicated our lives.
And he introduces five essential literacies
for the 21st-century.
And you'll be able to buy the book for $10
in the back at the end of this talk thanks
to Books Inc.
And if you're not able to buy it today, you
can go back to Books Inc. and all you need
to do is show your Google badge.
And I really want this to be a conversation.
I'm really excited to be connecting him with
you guys.
Who are the makers, who are creating the tools
that are changing the way people are going
to be thinking and living in the 21st-century.
So I want to make sure you guys get a chance
to ask your questions.
And before I jump in, you probably should
know who I am.
My name is Mamie, I've been a Googler since
May 2006 so coming up on six years.
I've worked on grassroots innovation at Google
and now on the developer relations team.
So, to kick it off I want to ask the question
that's on all of our minds.
Is Google making us stupid?
>>Howard Rheingold: Well you know, I would
phrase that question differently.
But it's a really good question to start a
conversation.
And I strongly believe that if you believe
that or fear that our use of social media
are making us shallow then why not teach more
people how to swim and explore the deep end
of the pool.
Slight difference which I don't think is semantic,
which is I'm really a believer in human agency
and that technologies afford but don't compel
behavior.
>>Mamie: Okay, so over the last 20 years you've
written 'Tools for Thought', 'Virtual Communities
Virtual Realities', 'Smart Mobs' why 'Net
Smart'?
>>Howard: Well I've thought about this a lot.
I've been forced to think about it since I
wrote in 1985 about where were personal computers
going and 1993 about people socializing online.
In 2002 about the combination of the mobile
phone and the Internet and the PC.
And each point, the question arose either
from critics or from scholars or a question
that I ask myself which is, is this stuff
any good for us?
And I've concluded that the way you use a
search engine, the way you stream video from
a phone, the way you update your Facebook
status matters to you and to me and to everyone
because first of all these are the languages
that we need to know in order to succeed personally.
But, the way we use these media today are
going to strongly influence the way they are
used and misused for decades to come.
So I think you'll see that there is a theme
running through the book which I'm talking
about personal empowerment, but I'm also talking
about improving the commons.
And I think that that is the way to improve
the commons.
>>Mamie: So I know when you wrote Tools for
Thought, you were inspired by Doug Engelbart's
1962 Augmenting Human Intellect.
And I want to know, how do you respond to
that today?
Are we currently living in a future that he
envisioned?
>>Howard: Who here has read Doug Engelbart's
1962 paper?
Okay.
It's worth rereading.
I reread it just about every year.
But you want to go look at it.
It was written in 1962 and everything that's
happening here really flowed from that paper.
Literally.
People talk about the mouse, which is actually
hypertext using text processing which became
word-processing.
Mixing video and computer images.
His laboratory was the first network information
Center for the ARPANET.
So it's really kind of the root of the technology
we use today.
And in that paper, he talks about humans using
language artifacts, methodology and training.
I've talked to Doug over the years about this
and he notes the obvious which is that the
artifacts have multiplied multibillion fold.
The first electronic digital computer used
less RAM than an icon does on a PC today.
But the methodology and the training, maybe
less so the language, have not evolved so
much.
And I think that this is a fundamental issue
of literacy that faces us every time we have
the technical capabilities to communicate,
to encode and decode information in new ways.
>>Mamie: Great so you mentioned that literacy.
And in Net Smart, you define five essential
literacies for thriving in the 21st-century.
Attention, crap detection, participation,
collaboration and network smarts.
And I definitely want to use this conversation
to explore each of those literacies.
But first, what do you mean by literacy?
And what's the difference between a literacy
and a skill?
[Pause]
>>Howard: Well I'm, I use the metaphor of
swimming at the beginning.
If you're the only person in the world who
knows how to swim and you fall into deep water
it will serve you well.
If you're the only person in the world who
knows how to ride a bicycle, you can still
get from place to place faster.
If you're the only person in the world who
knows how to read and write, or the only person
who knows how to make a link on a webpage,
it's not gonna serve you that well.
It's not gonna serve anybody else that well.
So all of the literacies I talk about attention,
participation, collaboration, crap detection
and network know-how have to do with both
the skill of encoding and decoding.
A fundamental alphabetic literacy and ability
to read and write.
But beyond that individual skill, the ability
to use that skill in concert with others.
There is a social connection to all of the
skills that we use not only with digital production
media, but with the digital networks that
propagate and communicate information.
>>Mamie: And so why is attention the fundamental
literacy for and always on the world?
>>Howard: You know, I think I have a slide
here that's kind of interesting.
Let me search through it.
Oops, I don't have that slide.
I had a, I took a screen grab from that mall
surveillance camera that I'm sure you've all
seen this.
It's had millions of hits on YouTube of the
young woman who fell into the fountain while
she was texting.
Pew Internet and American Life Studies have
surveyed Americans, and one in six have admitted
into running into something while looking
at their phone.
And then of course there is what happens when
you're in a classroom.
If you are professor in a classroom today,
you face students who are looking at their
laptops.
If you are a Googler in a meeting these days,
you are facing people who are looking at their
laptops.
So attention is a fundamental building block
of how we think and communicate in any case.
But the media that we carry with us these
days really affords distraction.
And I really make the distinction; I don't
think that online media, social media compelled
distraction.
But they afforded.
And the difference of course is what we know,
and what we intend to do.
>>Mamie: Hmm
And now, so in 2010 Eric Schmidt had this
crazy statistic that every two days humans
produce as much information as they did between
the era of cave paintings to 2003.
And I know people including MG Siegler are
declaring e-mail bankruptcy.
But this isn't the first time that humans
have suffered from information overload.
So I want to ask, how to we learn from history?
>>Howard: well firstly I'll quote Clay Shirky
who often says that there is no such thing
as information overload, it's just filter
failure.
And I will have to acknowledge, we all have
to acknowledge that Eric Schmidt's quote means
that the quantitative difference, and the
leap that we're taking today means a qualitative
difference.
But when I was looking into this issue of
information overload in the book, I discovered
that this is really not the first time that
we've dealt with new communication media exploding
dramatically.
The amount of information that's available
to people.
That little clay tablet there is one of the
artifacts that led Denise Schmandt-Besserat
to figure out where writing came from.
Writing was originally about accounting, but
it was later exapted to use to encode other
kinds of knowledge.
And I think that idea of exaptation that humans
tend to do both biologically and intellectually.
To adapt something that was involved or invented
for one purpose to serve another purpose will
serve us well.
The idea of information overload goes at least
back to the fourth century BC with Ecclesiastes.
We also saw in the wake of the Gutenberg revolution,
this quote from Adrien Baillet, "The multitude
of books which grows every day in a prodigious
fashion will make the following centuries
fall into a state as barbarous as that of
the centuries that followed the fall of the
Roman Empire."
Then of course there was Vannevar Bush's 1945
article, 'As We May Think' in which he noted
that the summation of human experience is
being expanded at a prodigious rate, but the
means we use for threading through the consequent
maze to momentarily important items is the
same as was used in the days of square rigged
ships.
This article of course was an inspiration
to Doug Engelbart and others.
Every time a new communication information
technology makes a flood of information available,
people have responded to that by inventing
new ways to cope with it.
So when scribes hand wrote texts, we got libraries
and we got schools and we got scholars.
The first schools are really to teach people
how to read and write.
And of course the priesthood controlled who
had access to that literacy.
And the printing press really broke that open.
Too much printed information led to many,
many things that we take for granted every
day.
Alphabetization, indexes, subject headings,
authors, critics, editors.
A whole ecosystem of human and technical means
for dealing with information emerge from that.
Now this is a picture of Engelbart talking
about humans using language artifacts methodology
and training during the mother of all demos.
>>Mamie: And you've coined terms like virtual
communities and smart mobs.
And the word that seems to be defined in Net
Smart is info tension, so what do you mean.
>>Howard: Well when I talk about attention,
I'll talk about learning to manage our attention.
Maybe we'll get back to that in a little bit.
>>Mamie: Yeah
>>Howard: But I think, in particular, for
us, for people in this room.
Managing the way we pay attention to information
is particularly important.
And I've looked at ways in which we could
do that.
And I think it comes into really two different
categories.
But it comes down to developing a sense of
mindfulness.
Of how we are deploying our attention from
time to time.
And I'm sure that all of you are to some degree
experts in a way that many of my students
and others I speak to are not.
Mindfulness means being aware of the content
of your consciousness at the moment.
What are you paying attention to?
That sounds a little spiritual.
You can look at metacognition there's a good
Wikipedia entry about that.
Metacognition expands out a little bit to
say that not only is this a skill a learnable
skill for recognizing where you are deploying
your attention.
Developing an awareness of how you're using
your awareness.
But it also means knowing what all of the
different tools in your consciousness toolbox
are.
Focused attention, diffused attention, abstraction
and analysis.
Picking out the one that's useful for the
moment.
And I think that a lot of what click trances
about a lot of what people fear with distraction
online has to do with a lack of decision-making
about how you're going to spend your attention
from moment to moment.
>>Mamie: So attention can be trained?
>>Howard: I think so and I've worked on it
with my students.
I worked on it with myself.
I shared some of it with you.
I divide that into the cognitive part, and
the part that has to do with how you arrange
your information tools.
Because we all need to make decisions on a
second by second, or microsecond by microsecond
basis.
What are you going to pay attention to?
There is that, if it wasn't for the fact that
it was easy to change our attention from what
we think we're supposed to be doing we would
not have to preponderance of cute cat videos.
You will click on that link.
You will look at that video.
You will see the little red badge that tells
you you've got more e-mail or that tells you
that there's an update in Facebook or G+.
And you're attracted to it without thinking
about it.
So the first part of this training is to try
to make those decisions more deliberately.
And at first, that's slow.
Sometimes you open a tab, you're gonna check
it out later.
Sometimes you tag it, bookmark it because
you may not check it out later but when you
want to look for it you will be able to find
it more easily.
So a method of training, that part of it has
to do with matching your attention to the
way your tools look on the screen.
And I'll get back to that and show you that.
I developed this from what I learned from
Professor BJ Fogg at Stanford.
Who's got a course on developing new habits.
And he says start small, find a place for
it and repeat.
So I guess I don't have that other slide there,
but what I do is write down at the beginning
of the day good old right brained hand writing
on a piece of 3 x 5 card maybe six or seven
words.
What are my two or three goals for the day?
Sometimes there are no particular goals.
I don't have a deadline.
Following each link where it leads is what
I'm supposed to do.
That's I discover things.
Some days I've done a deadline, I've got a
get a certain amount of words written by the
end of the day.
So I put that piece of paper in the periphery
of my attention and when my eyesight wanders,
it catches sight of that and I ask myself
what am I paying attention to right now?
And is that going to get me any closer to
where I'm going?
I actually learned this technique when I was
trying to learn how to do lucid dreaming.
Lucid dreaming is when you realize you're
in a dream and you begin directing the action.
The way you learn to do lucid dreaming is
you write 'am I awake' on a little piece of
paper.
You put in your pocket and you take it out
once an hour and you just develop the habit.
Eventually you do that in a dream and you
do a little reality test--
>>Audience: [Laughter]
>>Howard: find out.
But the best way to do it is to try to fly
and if you can fly you're pretty much assured—
>>Mamie: [Laughing]
That you're dreaming.
>>Audience: [Laughter]
>>Howard: You're in a dream.
You know I think that the same thing applies
to metacognition of attention online.
In that putting this piece of paper in the
periphery of my vision is not meant to police
me, but to develop a kind of inner observer
that becomes aware of how I'm paying my attention.
What I'm paying attention to.
>>Mamie: Hmm.
So I know that you turn to Dana Voight often.
And in this month's issue of 'Brown Alumni
Magazine', she's quoted as saying, "the goal
is to be peripherally aware of information
as it flows by, grabbing it at the right moment
when it is most relevant and valuable entertaining
or insightful."
And that really resonated with me as I read
your book.
And so how do your literacies enable us to
do that?
>>Howard: You know I've discovered this when
I assign my students to follow Twitter and
to create some RSS feeds.
And I came back the next week and they were
all panicked because they couldn't possibly
keep up with it.
And I realize that I had forgotten to frame
it with what I know, and what probably all
of you know which is that this is not a queue,
it's a stream.
You don't need to check each thing off like
a to-do list.
You can't.
You learn how to sample the stream.
You look at--
And a lot of the importance of RSS enables
you to scan headlines.
Or when you search, you get snippets.
So there are informational cues there in the,
our dashboards that we need to be able to
use more effectively.
>>Mamie: So once we are aware of what information
we are paying attention to, we need to validate
and verify and filter that information.
So tell us how can we all tune our internal
crap detectors?
>>Howard: So politely you can call this critical
consumption of information.
Hemingway used the term crap detectors.
He said every good journalist needs an internal
crap detector.
So I looked into the research on how people
search.
I'm sorry Dan Russell isn't here, he was one
of the sources for the book.
And I talked to Dan Russell, the search scientist
here.
I looked at a lot of the research particularly
on how young people search.
There's an extraordinarily large number of
young people who believe if it's on Google,
it must be true.
Of course when Mamie first started using search
engines, Google didn't exist it was AltaVista
and Infoseek.
I used MartinLutherKing.org.
Is everybody here aware, anybody here aware
of MartinLutherKing.org.
Have you ever heard of it before?
It's a good site to train people.
So it's one, two, third, it's the fourth hit
down on Google the last time I checked.
It's called Martin Luther King Jr.: a true
historical examination.
And it looks like a website about the civil
rights leader.
If you look at the articles though it takes
a really pretty radically dim view of Martin
Luther King Jr.
And there is an author here so when Mamie
said, "Well how do I know what's true and
what's not?"
I said, "Well you know, this is, you happen
to come along at a very unusual time.
For the last thousand years, the authority
was vested in the text.
You could take the book out of the library.
And you might disagree with this, it might
even be wrong.
But for the most part given that there was
an author, editor and publisher who try to
check some of the facts in it.
Or the truth claims in it."
Of course you put a term into a search engine,
there's no guarantee that what you get back
is going to the good information.
So one thing to do is look for an author,
and search on that author's name.
Which we were able to do here.
But we couldn't find an author for the site
itself.
So I told Mamie about WHOis.
Tell my students about WHOis.
Of course if you put MartinLutherKing.org
into WHOis it shows you someone by the name
of Don Black at Stormfront.org which turns
out to be a neo-Nazi community.
This is what's known as a cloaked site.
So I've developed a whole collection of sites
that I've shown to students to show them that
not everything you see online is for real.
The free online pregnancy test was a lot scarier
at first.
They didn't really clue you in to it being
a joke.
Now they do.
But if you enter a name and click on start
pregnancy test a little flash animation comes
up and says sit still while we scan you.
I entered the name Joe, turns out that Joe
is with child.
>>Audience: [Laughter]
>>Howard: I couldn't help but click on the
next one to find out that it's a girl of course.
Then I ask "Who's the daddy?"
>>Audience: [Laughter]
>>Howard: and if you don't like that, you
can choose another one.
But by this point you've probably figured
out that it's a hoax.
But there are lots of sites like, this one
looks perfectly legitimate.
Nicely designed website.
This is about a primate, a mandrel that's
been trained to understand English and respond
with the keyboard.
Totally nonexistent.
A lot of teachers use this one.
There's the endangered Pacific Northwest tree
octopus a completely nonexistent species.
So in the book I go into a lot of detail about
this, particularly when you're talking about
medical information, Googling your symptoms.
There are tools that we can use to find out
whether the advice we're gonna get is gonna
kill us or help cure us.
But I think we have to start by thinking like
a journalist or thinking like a detective.
And not assuming anything, and looking for
clues.
I think searching to learn is very important
if you, not just looking for where's the nearest
pizza joint.
You're trying to learn about something, don't
just stop at the first page of results.
Look at the snippets that you get and refine
your search from what you see in the snippets.
They often teach you about that.
Look for authors and search on their names
and triangulate like any good journalist does.
I remember being online when a rumor came
across on Twitter that Egypt had shut down
Internet access.
Which comes under the category of interesting
if true.
But there was nothing on Al Jazeera, there
was nothing on CNN, there was nothing on BBC.
So I put out an inquiry on Twitter about if
anybody could give me information that would
help me verify that.
One person reminded me that someone I do know
is in touch with people in the Middle East
and was talking on the phone to someone in
Egypt.
And I direct messaged them and he verified
it.
Someone reminded me of Ping.
I tried some websites in Egypt and they were
down.
Finally I saw a news report online.
So with three, I was confident that I could
pass this information along without it being
a false rumor.
Not long before or after that was the Haitian
earthquake.
And there was a rumor that also went around
on Twitter that if you texted a certain phone
number it would send money to send medical
personnel to Haiti.
And that turned out to be a cruel hoax.
So I think it's important for people to triangulate,
to crap detect themselves before they pass
information along.
And I think also you probably heard Ellie
Pariser spoke here; speak here about the filter
bubble.
And some years ago there was Cass Sunstein
who wrote in the 'Daily We' about his fear
that now that we can roll our own news we're
going to be paying more and more attention
to sources that we agree with.
And a lot of the social psychologist research
shows that groups of people who are more homogeneous
in opinion tend to make more radical decisions.
So I make it, I make sure that there is someone
in my personal learning network whose blog
I follow or who I follow on Twitter or otherwise
pay attention to regularly.
Someone who's intelligent and knowledgeable
but with whom I disagree strongly about a
number of things.
So if nobody in your network annoys you maybe
you're in an echo chamber.
So I think we're really talking about a combination
of algorithmic social and cognitive tools
we need to use.
This is not rocket science, it's not even
learning the multiplication tables.
It's just that this has happened so fast,
you're not taught how to search and how to
crap detect in school before you do it.
>>Mamie: And because you brought up search,
I just want, one question I want this audience
to think about is it our responsibility not
only to give people answers but to teach them
how to ask the right questions?
And how to verify those answers.
So something to think about.
And you brought up news and journalism.
And we do all have these broadcasting tools
in our pocket.
So does that make us all journalist?
>>Howard: Well you know one of the things
I wrote in 'Smart Mobs' is that it's not hard
to predict that any day now there will be
a world changing news event that will be streamed
or sent directly to the Internet from someone's
phone.
And I think the first real worldwide one was
the July 2007 tube bombing in London where
there is a very blurry picture from someone's
phone that was sent from there.
So we now have hundreds of millions of reporters.
And I would say that that's a great thing.
And that we now are able to crowd source information
that you wouldn't be able to get a reporter
on-site to before.
I think that if you take reports and you look
for ways to verify those reports you find
what are the different points of view about
this report.
Can I find a spokesperson for the different
points of view?
Can I put that all together into a short compelling
narrative that people are going to want to
pay attention to?
That's what journalists have always done whether
they were working with pencils and papers,
whether they were working with search engines
and smart phones.
And I think the difference between a reporter
and a journalist does have to do with that
set of procedures that they do.
Can more people do that kind of journalism?
Absolutely.
I don't think that we want to classify having
the ability to take a picture or stream video
as being a journalist.
I think, you are reporting on something.
>>Mamie: Hmm, so there is a theme throughout
the book that a firm grasp of these literacies
will allow you to multiply the value of a
public good, while also serving your own self-interest.
And this is connected to what Tim O'Reilly
calls the architectures of participation.
So tell us more about that—
>>Howard: I was—
>>Mamie: What does that mean?
>>Howard: I was struck by architectures of
participation when I wrote 'Smart Mobs'.
Because we've always used communication media
to do things together in new ways, whether
that's writing or print or the telephone.
The particular architecture of the Internet
allows us to do things that weren't really
possible before.
I think, well obviously Google is billed both
on attention and in architecture of participation.
If millions of people did not put links on
their website, you wouldn't have page rank.
But essentially what page rank is doing is
it's taking that human judgment, that attention
that a blogger or anybody else puts a link
on the webpage.
They're saying if you're paying attention
to me you should pay attention to this.
So add in the secret sauce of the formula
that attention aggregated becomes a very valuable
public good.
I don't think people appreciate what a miracle
free search is.
And of course it's not free, were paying with
our attention.
And you make some very good money by selling
that attention to advertisers.
And another great example was Napster.
When Napster first came out, people didn't
download music from a server they downloaded
music from other Napster users that had the
music on their PCs.
By default the folder that you download all
your music to on Napster is open to everyone
else who's on Napster at that moment for them
to download.
So this is a unique situation in which a population
is able to provision a resource, and the act
of consuming it.
And I think that that is new.
And it is afforded by the architecture of
participation.
Corrie Doctorow calls this in reference to
the tragedy of the comments problem, sheep
that shit grass.
So I think that we are seeing a lot of different
ways that people are able to use online platforms
to coordinate all kinds of collective action.
And that architectures of participation taken
together with our knowledge of how to use
them is going to enable us to do things that
are even more fantastic than what we're able
to do now.
>>Mamie: So what are the different forms of
participation?
>>Howard: So participation, you know, there
are a jillion ways to participate.
I just noted a few examples to draw these
people's attention to the importance of knowing
how to participate.
There was a Harry Potter website that was
shut down by Warner Bros. a few years ago.
And Heather Lawver organized a worldwide boycott
of Warner Bros. and had the Warner Bros. lawyers
back off their injunction before they found
out that she was 16 years old.
Bev Harris was a pretty obscure blogger before
she found the source code for the Diebold
voting machines online, and circulated that.
Some students at Swarthmore put it up on the
Swarthmore server.
They were sued by Diebold and federal court
found that Americans do have the right to
know how their voting machines work.
She was an obscure blogger, she wasn't very
obscure for very long, that climbed the power
law curve to the A-list bloggers very quickly.
You all know who this is, and there's a certain
amount of controversy about the role of social
media in the Middle East and North Africa
and what's sometimes called Arab spring.
But there's no doubt that it played an essential
role.
So talking about people who start multibillion
dollar industries when they're 19 or 20 or
21 years old.
I emphasize the youth of all these people
simply to emphasize that this new literacy,
the ability to know how to participate can
lead to real economic and political and cultural
power.
We've got a huge number of ways to participate.
And I love Ross Mayfield's power law of participation
in which he plots a threshold with a tool.
How easy is it to do with the degree of engagement
of the community?
And you can start out by, if you are yet another
reader of somebody's blog or another follower
of them on Twitter.
You're kind of adding to their installed attention
base.
But you can plus things, you can like things,
you can begin tagging and commenting.
You can climb that curve, and by the time
that you climb that curve you are engaged
in a lot of pretty sophisticated ways of participating
online.
I call one out here.
I talk about in my talks.
In the book I get into a lot of detail about
the different ways of participation.
But curation I think is a very easy lightweight
way for people to participate in filtering
the web for each other.
Crap detection of course only eliminates the
bad stuff.
How do we float the good stuff up to the top?
And so page rank is one way to do it.
But also socially, were beginning to curate
with each other.
And I know that Google is getting with that
idea as well.
And we've got all kinds of platforms that
are popping up.
Most people have heard of Pinterest.
But there's also Scoop.it, Pearltrees, Storify.
This seems like a natural for Google.
It seems to me that curation is a fundamental
literacy that is spreading through the population
very quickly.
So benefits, we all need to transform information
overload into useful knowledge.
We need to make those decisions about the
utility of all the information that comes
across.
The architecture of participation means that
there is no additional cost to make your decision,
your private decision public.
And in open-source programming it's called
scratching an itch.
When a new printer is created and there's
no driver for it and you might as well write
it yourself.
You might as also contribute that to the public
code base.
Not only are you signaling that you are a
person worth collaborating with, cooperating
with.
But you are recruiting a team so that when
they change the hardware and that printer
you've got some people to help you change
that.
So self-interest that adds up to a public
good.
Again this is something that echoes a lot
in the book.
If you want to establish a reputation of knowing
which are talking about a subject then every
day tell people I've looked at 100 different
websites.
And if you are interested in this particular
niche these are the five that you ought to
pay attention to.
If they are interested in that subject, they
will know whether you know what you're talking
about and spread the word.
In fact I think this is like personal search
engine optimization.
If you are curating topics that you feel you
have some expertise on, people who are looking
for information on that topic, people who
are looking for experts, are going to find
you that way.
Now of course we've got knowledge sharing
as a form of participation.
You've got stack overflow.
You've got Quora.
I think we are only just beginning to see
the different ways that people can participate.
And Henry Jenkins calls the aggregation of
a sufficient number of knowledgeable participators
"participatory culture."
It makes the point that a person who sees
themself as a passive consumer culture as
a difference since of agency as a citizen
than someone who sees himself in however small
a way as a producer of culture.
Whether it's just that they're tagging or
commenting.
And we've got a jillion different ways to
participate.
And a new one coming up every day.
So I think the proliferation of literacies
about different ways of participating are
enabling people to make their own way personally
and professionally more effectively.
But in the aggregate, they're adding up to
things that are useful to all of us.
>>Mamie: So moving onto the next literacy,
I want to know how your thoughts about collaboration
changed and evolved since Smart Mobs.
>>Howard: So, well I've been thinking about
this since 1987 when I wrote about virtual
communities.
>>.Mamie: Hmm
>>Howard: It was very exciting to me that
I could sit in my room which I'd been doing
with a typewriter for years and communicate
with other people and share knowledge with
other people.
So now the forms of collaboration.
Of collective action.
Of cooperation.
And there's slightly different definitions—
>>Mamie: Yeah.
>>Howard: for each of those.
Are proliferating.
And I think this is probably the most powerful
aspect of the cultural revolution we are going
through now.
Just as the invention of speech was an extremely
powerful cultural revolution.
The invention of writing was an extremely
powerful revolution.
It was what literate people did with those
tools.
They invented civilization and democracy and
science.
So I wrote about smart mobs 10 years ago.
This picture was from Chile.
When I went to Chile and talked about smart
mobs there, they said "Oh yes the Penguin
Revolution."
Students in Chile wear black and white and
gray uniform so they called them penguins.
They objected to the very poor funding of
public education in Chile by chaining this
schools shot and hitting the streets with
700,000 other Chileans.
They are still leading a very active dialogue
about the role of education in that country.
And of course we're seeing Arab Spring; we're
seeing Occupy Wall Street.
All kinds of ways that people are able to
organize collective action with people they
weren't able to organize with before.
And at speeds and at scales and in places
they weren't able to organize before.
And this is only beginning to play out.
So, as I said I wrote about virtual communities
in 1987.
It was pretty obscure then; in fact it took
me till 1992 to talk a publisher into backing
a book on this.
I was told only electrical engineers will
want to use computers to communicate with.
So it's kind of hard in retrospect to see
how odd it was to do that.
But nowadays, whether you are a gamer or you
are a cancer patient you are probably connecting
with people that you didn't know before and
may never meet face-to-face, but who play
a very important role in your life.
Of course now we've got distributed computations
started with SETI@Home.
I usually need to explain this to people—
>>Mamie: Not this one, yes.
>>Howard: but don't need to explain it here.
Folding.stanford.edu.
People can, in fact very recently Foldit the
game based on folding it home has enabled
a group of gamers to solve an important puzzle
about the way protease, the enzyme protease,
very important in HIV research.
There was a problem about how it folds that
had not been solved before gamers did that
using distributed computation.
So we all know that in a few years most of
the human population will be walking around
carrying or wearing supercomputers linked
at speeds much greater than we consider to
be broadband today.
So what kind of computation are we going to
be able to do voluntarily?
You know when SETI@Home first started, they
were at some point the most powerful supercomputer
in the world.
19 teraflops.
And this was maybe close to a decade ago.
Now we've got crowd sourcing.
Who here knew Jim Gray, or knows the Jim Gray's
story?
So I will just briefly repeat it.
Jim Gray was a computer scientist at Microsoft
research working on distributed computation.
And since he was working on that, he had a
lot of friends in the industry.
He took his sailboat out one day in San Francisco
Bay a couple years ago and did not return
that evening.
His friends got the latest satellite photographs
from NASA from Google.
And Microsoft engineers cut up into half 1
million different images.
An Amazon put it up on Mechanical Turk.
Got a couple of thousand volunteers to search
3500 square miles of ocean.
They did not find Jim Gray.
But what was particularly interesting to me
about it was that people put this together
with ad hoc tools within hours of Jim Gray
being reported missing.
So crowd sourcing is not just about a business
getting its customers to do work for them.
It's about any way that you can cut a task
up into a lot of small pieces and somehow
induce a population to engage in it.
Now we've got crowd funding with this jobs
act.
The SEC has now made it legal for startups
to take up to $2 million in kick starter type
funding.
Now we're hearing talk of collaborative consumption.
There's a book about collaborative consumption.
Probably a lot of you have used airbnb.
The ability to share your apartment, share
your automobile.
These are all things that people weren't able
to do before because we weren't able to find
out where's the nearest one and when's it
available.
So again this architecture of participation
as it becomes more sophisticated, more location
aware, more time aware, it enables people
to build on those platforms more things that
they can do together.
And of course collective intelligence, Wikipedia
is not the end of this.
Any time that people can put a small piece
of the puzzle together and have that add up
to something that makes sense to a lot of
people I think is really important.
And now we are seeing with You2Me and Khan
Academy and P2PU.
There are actually dozens of these platforms
for people to learn with each other.
You know you've, we've never had the ability
before to find out how to do things instantaneously.
You can learn how to configure a Drupal installation
or tie your shoes on YouTube.
Nowadays people are using those things to
learn cooperatively.
And I think we're really just at the beginning
of that.
All of these involve a certain know how.
And people who have that know-how will be
able to summon these resources more effectively
than people who don't.
>>Mamie: So jumping ahead to the last literacy.
>>Howard: Yeah.
>>Mamie: What does it mean to be a networked
individual and why are networks important?
>>Howard: Well you know a lot of the terms
about network awareness.
And a lot of the little pieces of lore come
from different disciplines.
So there's people in sociology and a network
science.
So network science is a new one.
So we've learned about small worlds.
We've learn about the power law.
We've learned about the long tail.
These all have applications in many different
fields.
Biology and chemistry and astrophysics.
But the lesson for everybody is that the structure
of networks influences the kinds of behavior
that can take place in those networks.
And the person who knows how a small world
network works is going to be more effective
online.
A lot of the ideas like the presentation of
self, Erving Goffman wrote about this decades
before the Internet existed.
We all give information to others about who
we want them to think we are.
We all give off information to others about
that they are able to detect about who they
think we are.
A lot of these ideas about identity and individual
is network individualism moves from the kind
of community centric era of the virtual community
where you found people who were sharing a,
their interest in a particular subject they
connected with the individuals.
Now of course we carry our networks in our
pocket.
We're able to summon our social networks and
were at the center of our social network.
And they're intersecting.
There's a difference between a group with
sociologists say is densely knit.
Most of the people in the group know each
other and is tightly bound.
There are very few connections with the outside
world.
And a network which is sparsely knit there
are a lot of people in my network and in your
network who don't know each other.
And it's loosely bound.
There are people from outside the network,
in fact that's how a small world network happens.
A small number of connections in Italy.
If I know someone in Italy, I get information
to them much, much faster just that way.
So a lot of these ideas that sociologists
have been looking at.
Social capital is a particularly useful one.
The idea that people can get things done together
outside the formal institutions of contracts
or laws.
How do they do that?
Well there's bridging capital, there's bonding
capital and there is reciprocity.
One of the things I discovered looking at
the sociology of reciprocity is that there
is empirical research that shows that the
probability that someone will offer you help
online is most strongly predicted by whether
you have offered help to others online.
So I think, as I said this is not rocket science
or algebra but if you learn about the ways
this strong ties and weak ties are important
to people.
If you learn the way that social media and
viral media are adding up to what Manuel Castells
is calling a networked society.
He has said with a lot of empirical backup
that it's not really accurate to say were
in an information society.
We are in a networked society and we've always
been involved in social networks.
But the technical network that connects us
today amplified that innate human sociology
in ways that make all kinds of things that
used to be impossible possible.
Networked publics and the connections between
these I think make for someone who's got network
know-how.
>>Mamie: So before we turn it over to Googlers.
You know these are the people who are building
these tools.
So I wanted to give you a chance to sort of
what your parting questions for this audience?
What you want these guys leaving with?
>>Howard: So to what degree are you in the
know how business?
And how do you extend that?
I remember that Microsoft had a really famous
failure when they had the talking paperclip.
Remember the talking paperclip—
>>Mamie: Clippy
>>Howard: It's tremendously annoying.
It's a hard problem.
How do you, you've got a lot of data about
how people behave and you don't want to freak
them out about that either.
So I think that there is some Googlers who
like hard problems.
I think the hard problem not just how do you
improve search, how do you include more and
more information in the information you're
organizing but how do you enable people to
climb that power law of participation?
How do you enable them to learn to search
to learn more effectively?
One you know when I was looking at the crap
detection of medical information, the National
Institutes of Health do have a browser add-on.
So when you are browsing to websites that
claim to have medical information, you can
find out whether they approve or not.
So I think, and I'm sure that you are thinking
about this.
There's some combination of crowd sourced
social crap detection, social verification.
And algorithmic ways of determining it that
we need to develop.
The more bad information there is online,
the more crucial that information is.
The more effective we need to make the ways
we evaluate that information as individuals.
>>Mamie: and we have a microphone so I want
to invite you guys to ask questions.
>>male#1: I have a question related to the
concept of the filter bubble.
You mentioned that a strategy for avoiding
that is seeking dissenting opinions or at
least including some of those.
I think there's a risk there that you end
up with not being able to tell what the truth
is because you just hear two different sides
of a story.
And in a lot of recent current events there
definitely two completely opposing sides to
the story and it's almost impossible to know
what the truth is.
So my question is what are your thoughts about
whether the filter bubble is sort of a human
nature problem that people are going to gravitate
towards a position where they just vote based
on wishful thinking?
And what are some strategies that people can
use to avoid that and get to actual truth
as opposed to pleasing fiction?
>>Howard: Well the actual truth of the melting
point of sodium is pretty easily determined.
The actual truth of did this person commit
a crime?
We've developed this system where we have
advocates for both sides and we randomly select
people to make a decision.
So I think that there's really a continuum.
The word truth, we tend to put a T on that
and think that there is a truth.
You know I noted on, I noted this thing about
if there isn't someone in your network who
you regularly disagree with or who regularly
annoys you then you're in an echo chamber.
And someone else on Twitter said nobody in
their network disagreed about the Trayvon/Zimmerman
case.
And I said "Well, is nobody talking about
the rights of the accused here?"
And the person immediately went off on an
advocacy of arresting this person.
But of course the law is about protecting
the rights of the most despised.
So we develop these institutions to deal with
some of the problems that have arisen from
human natural capacities to believe what they
want to believe.
Cognitive dissonance.
There's a whole psychological study about
how people will, and you can influence people's
beliefs very, very easily by showing them
information in one way or the other.
So the truth is hard to find.
I think just knowing that you can't accept
all the information that comes across your
screen at face value is very significant.
There's a difference there in terms of truth
seeking.
I think the scientific method was a great
advance in truth seeking.
We can argue theologically and philosophically
about things that can never be proven.
But if we're arguing about the melting point
of sodium than let's just get that sodium
out and a thermometer and find out.
[Pause]
>>male#2: Hi.
One of the things that I find very disturbing
at work is that we continue to use e-mail
in ways that seem inappropriate.
I mean I think it's great for a conversation,
but we use it to indicate status changes in
all sorts of things like that.
And I was wondering, but I can't think of
an alternative that would work as well because
e-mail is so universal.
I was wondering if you had any thoughts about
alternatives to e-mail that we should be working
on.
>>Howard: You know I ranted about this for
so long so long ago that I actually stopped
ranting about it.
But you know there's some basic literacies.
How about having an appropriate subject line,
or a subject line at all.
Or a subject line that doesn't say about your
e-mail.
People here are more sophisticated than that.
But believe me, most of the people in the
enterprise world are not.
How about not CCing everybody in the world.
I did a, there was something when I was doing
consulting for a company in Asia.
And someone sent out a message saying the
Singapore office will be closed on Friday.
And I'm in California.
So I found out how many people receive that
message.
17,000 people in the world had to know that
the Singapore office was closed on Friday.
A lot of these things are best done with wikis,
and you know that.
And Google Docs.
It's a matter of training people to use them.
>>male#2: You gave me a couple ideas, thank
you.
>>Mamie: Cool.
I think we are out of time.
But thank you for coming and you can buy books
in the back.
>>Howard: And I'll sign them
[Applause]